this is a production of cornell
university
this is frank rossi for the cornell turf
grass video log
and we're talking about annual bluegrass
seed heads in the lawn
now in your lawn areas you'll often see
seed heads in the spring
particularly on annual bluegrass now in
most lawns annual bluegrass is going to
function as a true winter annual
which means it germinates from seed in
the fall over winters as a clump of
tillers
and then the following spring you'll see
it produce flowers
which is the seed heads that you see now
those seed heads
is the shift of the plant from the
reproductive phase
from the vegetative phase to the
reproductive phase and then
after that reproductive phase that
tiller will die
you will see a natural thinning in that
lawn on the other side of that annual
bluegrass
as a winter annual wants to go through
the summer as a seed
not as a plant the only reason annual
bluegrass would ever survive
in most of our lawn situations is
because we're sustaining it with lots of
water and fertilizer
through the summer months otherwise that
plant would easily just
die off after the flowering so be
mindful of that that you will cease a
natural decline in the lawn
after the annual bluegrass seed heads
are produced
and if you want to get them off of
course a rotary mower
will be able to take the seed heads off
long term if you want to solve that
problem there are very few chemical
options
but there are some that are available
for the most part the best thing to do
is to just let it dry out
and then as it thins out you can reseed
those patches come the following fall
this is frank rossi for the cornell turf
grass video
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu